I mean I had to argue with my daughter
when I first came out of politics um
Harry Styles was wearing a dress
and um my daughter is a huge fan and uh
we got into our argument she started
crying
and I was just trying to figure out what
comes at the time my daughter was like
13 like why are you crying I'm just
spitting facts here this is not imp
opinions and she started telling me
about
you know guys getting pregnant and I was
like she just didn't know because I had
never sat down with her and she was on
social media so what what did you say
like
I said
I was something about the dress and
being a guy wearing a dress yeah I was
like well that's uh I mean anybody could
wear a dress I was like but I I told her
the reason why he's wearing the dress
she said but he's cute I think it looks
great on him I said no it's no it's not
it doesn't look great on them you're 13.
you don't you're highly impressionable
yeah so it's like like like people with
Kanye when she came when he came on here
people stood up for Kanye what he did
when he came in when he was totally in
the wrong it's because they love his
music they're biased they're not
thinking she was a huge the Harry Styles
fan and she wasn't listening and
whatever I said it hurt her feelings and
now she's 20 and she's and we was the
same weight growing up looking at
Madonna listen to her music I never
understood what parents is like don't
watch her she's she's Satan you know as
I got older it makes more sense now
these people are put in in positions of
power just highly over highly
impressible kids and they're there to
manipulate them and have them think and
act and and I think nowadays both
certain way
I thought that it was just so improbable
that people were trying to sexualize
Society on purpose that was real then I
started hearing about that I just
learned about this Kinsey guy this uh
learned about a little while ago this
sex doctor from the 1930s 40s 50s and
Hugh Hefner was his student yeah and
they were overtly attempting to
sexualize college kids like they would
go to college campus we are going to
sexualize society so I guess we're still
seeing this yeah the grooming stuff's
real man yeah yeah totally so about the
celebrity stuff I remember I was working
for one non-profit and they were like
I'm a big fan of Death Cab for Cutie and
they said who wants to go see a death
camp concert and I was like are you
kidding and like it was really popular
with college kids at the time and so
they said anybody who volunteers to do
voter registration at the event gets an
all-access pass and I was like I'm done
you tell me where and when they give me
an all-access pass they give me a stack
of voter registration forms and said go
out and just ask people I got to hang
out backstage and meet the band so right
there they're like they're very very
clever in how they do this stuff now I'm
not saying anything about the band and
wasn't doing anything right but this
organization knew to go after young
people in these spaces to exploit the
celebrity because they knew I would do
it for them and I was like I don't know
I was like 20 years old yeah yeah well
like that's why the uh Biden talked to
cardi B that's why they talked to the
Rock I mean yeah influence because 40 of
this country is not in the politics but
they'll go do what cardi B says or The
Rock Says that's why they do it because
he's doing all right cardi B's you know
sort of been calling calling it out you
know what I mean have you seen your
stuff yeah
that's right I hit a lid this is seven
dollars
you're going to the Gucci store behind
your list but the rock looks broke he
looks like he'll back any candidate for
any amount of money he he's he's he has
no tweets no shame at all he did a tweet
and that I think uh three it was exact
on the date 365 day where he you know he
was endorsing them and I responded to
him I said today I want you to remember
the day you you uh recommended the worst
president and worst vice president in
our history I think it was on Instagram
yeah because that dude I you can't tell
me he wasn't paid money to do that yeah
he supported Gavin Newsom when Gavin
Newsom had this whole scandal with the
restaurant he supported any politician
that will just probably give him a
little bit of money yeah yeah that's
what a lot of these that's what a lot of
these celebrities do they're like oh you
want me to support you how much are you
willing to give me yeah that's that's
how it works exactly that is absolutely
selling out this country most
importantly it's like just like John
Cena with his uh you know Mandarin
and that's okay you're allowed to
apologize to China you're allowed to
wear a dress but they're going to ban
you if you've got conservative opinions
why because they want to make sure that
kids only hear one side of the equation
10 years the 10 year old kid
eight-year-old kid right now say
eight-year-old kid goes on Tick Tock
Goes to School teachers are grooming
them and all that stuff 10 years from
now that kid's gonna be voting who do
you think they're going to vote for oh
yeah yeah unless y'all start speaking up
showing up to skate events this Saturday
10 a.m there you go and just saying look
man
that's what I tell people you don't need
to come out and and wave an American
flag and scream Trump's name out loud
you don't got to put on Q Shaman horns
right and and scream as loud as you can
all you got to do is mind your own
business and just be like
all you gotta do is mind your own
business and just be like I don't know
about all that that's it
when someone comes to you and says you
know man it's like these trumps that
were so bad like they're all nasty
people just go I don't know about all
that yeah huh interesting no no I don't
know about all that like I don't believe
that's that you don't have to respond to
people that's something that's important
for people to understand I think in
reality you never have to respond right
you might be even in court played the
fifth you know you don't even have to
respond in court legally because we
realize it but ethically there's so many
questions that is are leading you
towards a way of answering you don't
have to respond to that stuff or you
just laugh and say yeah yeah was that
your brother's toilet war cry yeah I
don't know there's something wrong when
you guys were uh transitioning into
politics like what was that what was
your state of mind for the months before
that were you were you political before
um yeah I just kept it to myself and
when we came out we talked about and I
was like I didn't want to pretty much
alienate half my fan base you know and
that's exactly what we did we came out
it's just at first we tried to come in
neutral just more common sense and it
was still unsubscribed but still you
know saying horrible things about us and
calling the sellouts and Uncle Tom so I
said I just said I just went I just came
out with everything well we did come in
new to our first video that about the
kid we just said no one should be uh
attacked for wearing a shirt expressing
a freshman right whether he's wearing a
body shirt or a trump shirt no one
should ever be attacked for when Obama
shirt or anything and when we post that
top comment Trump supporters I knew it
I'm
subscribe it looks like it's not we lost
15 10 000 followers in like within an
hour yeah supposedly put up on Instagram
yeah it was really it was really weird
it doesn't it feel like aliens came and
infected their brain and took over their
bodies we took a picture with Trump like
a cardboard cutout yeah and we just put
up and we're just laughing in the in the
photo they thought it was actually
Donald Trump
I mean just how dumb I mean I'm not I'm
not saying they're dumb but people are
just so ignorant yeah it's like
I think that my world I mean I mean that
seriously I mean that figuratively but
it's like the NPC meme is real yeah
these are people who are just like
sitting there with their eyes glazed
over and drill coming out of their mouth
and then they're just like but Donald
Trump was bad and you're like yo it's a
cardboard cutout it's not a real Truck
Yeah but Donald Trump is bad my guy it's
a joke it's not you don't think you
can't you can't their brain is a rock
yeah yeah and uh and they can't even
prove that he's bad they've been taught
that he's bad yeah yeah I know that's a
thing it's like we said this is the
crazy thing about a show like this it's
like you know Luke's uh what are you an
anarchist I guess I'm like moderate
Ian's Wild Card all over the place we
bring in a lot of fascist liberals
yeah but the only thing that matters
doesn't matter whether you're pro-life
pro-choice pro-government again
anti-government protects Pro parks
department all that matters is are you
with the cult or against the cult
because if you're against the cult
you're a bad guy period no matter what
your opinions are right you come out and
you say to someone like I agree with
every single one of your opinions except
BLM
oh that's it you're a fraud yeah you're
a [ __ ] you're fired get out you're
you're a trump supporter I mean that
whole BLM that was just one of the
biggest frauds of the decade biggest
grips of our time a lot of that money
went to Democrat politicians that was
what was the worst part about it was the
misappropriated funds like people were
buying houses the woman bought a mansion
with them and what made it worse than
living around white people
with all kinds of police officers yeah
like well-funded police departments yeah
so that was a funny thing I remember
there was a BLM protest in Wisconsin we
talked about where there all these BLM
protesters outside of this guy's house
he brandishes a shotgun so they call the
police when the police come they're all
scream aiming and cheering you're like
wait hold on a minute this is a
conversation I've talked about like
people that are susceptible to Cults
people you might want to call them
stupid people with the eyes glazed over
they're in so much pain that they don't
even realize they're in pain but like I
think Klaus Schwab sits around with his
buddies at World economic form has the
same conversation like what do we do
with these people that are just willing
to worship the cult TV like what do we
do with them what's a what's an
industrious like what's a freedom loving
way to deal with them because otherwise
they want to put them in pods and have
them just create energy yeah typically
those people are very emotional you can
get to the coat strings just about
something that makes them feel sad or
happy yeah people that think that way
they're just very easy to manipulate it
because they don't have their emotions
in check anybody that way is like
talking to a brick wall yeah this is why
health I think is so important for me uh
and for a lot of different people
because if you don't have your health
right if your gut is not right your
brain can't be operating properly and if
your brain's not working properly you're
more emotional when you're emotion more
emotional you're less logical so I I
think first of all just just having a
conversation about mental health and
physical health I think that's the start
and I think naturally there's a reason
there's so many articles talking about
how you know right Wingers are more
prone to work out than left-wingers
there's a reason why there's this kind
of philosophy of personal responsibility
that's more prevalent on one side than
the other side so I think a lot of this
has to be done by Leading by example I
think we should never be telling people
exactly what to do I think through
empathy through conversations through
listening to people we could say hey let
me try to help you be the best version
of yourself and when you are you don't
need the government you don't need all
the consumers products you don't need
all this other bull crap that's
superficial that's made up that's
marketed to you that essentially take
away from your life and the your your
kind of uh you know source that you have
here on this planet you yourself are
becoming more of a self-independent
human being that is uh you know a person
that doesn't need anything and doesn't
feed the system yeah um you know but
I believe I believe in everything you
said but
so many people are just so dependent on
other people yeah people even more
depending on other people not
independent yeah they're easily gonna be
swimming it's like it's always gonna be
those people who just depending on other
people and they don't practice
self-accountability and
a lot of those people don't have
families too right so when you have a
family you have a family unit that is
able to depend on each other and help
each other out because not everyone's
going to be 100 personally responsible
and perfect all the time but if you have
a family member to help you out here and
I think this is why there has been such
a concerted effort and such an attack on
the family unit right through culture
through of course online pornography
through of course dating through of
course all the psyaps and psychological
warfare that's happening out there
because then if you're able to make an
individual just by themselves you're
able to make them a victim a lot easier
so so it's not that these people depend
on others is that they depend on
government they want the government to
step in because they have no one else in
their lives to help them or to back them
up so when they get a proposition like
hey the government's going to write you
a two thousand dollar check hey the
government's going to come in here and
give you free health care hey the
government's going to help you uh be
euthanized hey that you know people are
like yeah yeah that's give me give me
give me give me give me and then that
kind of that kind of existence where you
depend on others and and suck and be an
energy vampire is an existence that uh
people are trapped in the loop of and
and nudging them and at least having
them concentrate on their physical
health and mental health uh naturally I
think would lead to a solution to this
problem thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time